when i was just a newborn my grandmother
generously gifted me a certificate for a
single share of disney stock to
celebrate the price
one dollar and forty cents decades later
we fished that certificate out of our
safe and did a little research turns out
that little single share had made some
friends through multiple stock splits
and dividend investment we now owned
over 50 shares on top of that the share
price had grown to about 35 each so in
2007 we sold the shares for around 1600
which we ended up putting towards the
down payment on our first house all told
i realized a whopping 114
return on that investment way to go baby
phillip okay mr boss baby don't forget
that was thanks to your nana but now
that you can tie your own shoes and have
all these fancy financial licenses do
you have what it takes to pick a winner
like she did all those years ago not
only did i learn to tie my shoes thank
you very much but i have also learned
that there's a lot more to picking
stocks than following a gut instinct or
what i see on reddit today we're going
to explore the tools you can use to
become your very own baby phillip
moneybags mustache twirling required
[Music]
let's say a certain company has caught
your eye maybe they make a product you
love maybe you keep seeing their name
pop up on wall street bets or maybe you
simply work for the company and have an
opportunity to become a shareholder
before tapping that buy button on your
trading app it might be a good idea to
kick the tires so to speak most methods
of analyzing stocks fall into two major
categories technical analysis and
fundamental analysis they're often
portrayed as locked in an eternal battle
for supremacy same goal different
tactics so which camp comes out on top
let's start by looking at the technician
if you've ever seen a day trader at a
coffee shop or those huge stock
terminals on tv with squiggly lines and
red and green columns then you've seen
technical analysis in action this
discipline focuses on tracking price
movement and trading volume of a
company's stock what they're looking at
are historical patterns patterns that
will clue them into opportunities to
sell or buy a stock at a profit based on
the data this often requires extensive
research of past trends sophisticated
trading models and a healthy dose of
technology to execute when they
recognize the signal they're looking for
these repeatable patterns are discovered
through something called back testing
back testing is a critical concept to
the technician it suggests that specific
movements of the stock price or trading
volume will be repeated in the future
here's an example of the cup and handle
here's a candlestick and of course the
falling knife
many traders develop entire strategies
around a single pattern or a combination
of multiples but mapping the stock price
alone isn't the only factor they
consider another is the moving average
this is a constantly updating average
price or trading volume of a stock
one classic use of this particular
indicator is the crossover strategy this
strategy looks for a share price to fall
below or climb above a moving average
hence crossover they use these shifts as
a signal to buy or sell out of their
position but crossovers are just the
beginning strategies like pennants flags
or triangles are other configurations
analysts might look for
now that our brains are good and
scrambled let's visit the other side the
fundamentalist fundamental analysts
aren't concerned with all the squiggly
lines and fine details of a stock's
movement instead fundamentalists focus
on the overall strength and financial
stability of a company they ask
questions like how profitable were they
last year are they in a strong position
to weather an economic downturn are they
currently undervalued obviously you
can't just set a meeting with the cfo to
get answers to these questions so these
investors rely on a few specific
formulas
if you were to do an online search for
any company stock you'll likely come
across two essential fundamental
indicators earnings per share or eps and
price to earnings or pe
eps for a company is found by taking the
company's net income subtracting
preferred dividends if any then dividing
that number by the number of shares
outstanding the higher the eps the more
profitable the company
then if you take their eps and divide it
into the current stocks share price
you'll have your p e ratio these ratios
will allow you to compare a stock apples
to apples or apple to samsung for
example let's say you're interested in
two companies donut dragons and cupcake
queens
after you run the numbers you see that
donut dragons has a higher eps than
cupcake queens suggesting a higher
profitability further crunching reveals
that donut dragons also has a lower p e
ratio than cupcake queens meaning it
might be a cheaper buy
analysts use all kinds of creative
ratios like this to help measure the
fundamental value of one company over
another i'll admit the idea that i can
just use math to make money is really
appealing
it gives the individual a sense of
control over something as uncontrollable
as an economic market and even though
these two analytical paths can help you
make a more informed decision we can't
forget that there are important aspects
to a company's health that are neither
technical nor fundamental in nature
these are known as qualitative elements
does the company have a durable
competitive advantage how's the
management at the top what's their
turnover like what direction does this
company's industry seem to be heading
even if you're able to find some of this
out the information is going to be
interpreted through the lens of your
personal feelings maybe you feel that a
company while booming now is ultimately
doomed due to climate change maybe after
hearing about a leadership scandal you
decide to sell despite what the p e
ratio might tell you that's okay
you should allow space for your
excitement and personal values to have a
seat at the decision making table
so which of these philosophies
ultimately wins out should you lean into
technical analysis or focus on
fundamentals maybe qualitative research
is ultimately the most important
for many investors professional and
novice alike these different approaches
actually aren't in a battle at all
instead when used in tandem they
complement each other in 2019 warren
buffett told his shareholders his three
general rules for choosing a company to
invest in
first they must earn good returns on the
net tangible capital required in their
operation
second they must be run by able and
honest managers finally they must be
available at a sensible price
as you can see even the oracle of omaha
uses a three-pronged approach
now if all this makes your head spin
that's okay this kind of stuff isn't for
everyone and you don't have to do it in
order to be a successful investor but if
solving this puzzle and picking stocks
is of interest to you and you have time
go for it start small and do your own
work to verify anything you might see on
the internet the point of all this isn't
to become some sort of magical stock
soothsayer impervious to losses rest
assured there is no such thing the goal
is to make you a more confident and
informed investor
and that's our two cents
quick before you go
do you know what you want to be when you
grow up no matter your answer we think
you should check out future of work a
new six-part docu-series on pbs voices
hosted by julia and me that explores the
real big work-related questions that
americans are facing today everything
from debt and the gig economy to career
identity and so much more check it out
link in our description and be sure to
tell them that two cents sent you
[Music]
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
patron
[Music]
you